how's the Gomer as my name's Pam welcome
to thieve town you're the lyrtle okay
let's go in here
wait are we together um I don't know I
don't know this game I think one of us
is a traitor and we have to figure out
who it is so okay here says Lenin Spock
your friends stab repeat watched I'm
okay
oh so I don't know who you are and you
don't know who I am
I Know Who I am
does I have to figure out what someone
stabbed okay I stab you I stab you
because I'm that awesome it's really
hard to figure it out
right yeah did you miss yeah you stabbed
me
time for a jewel where they are they
where are you
I'm up here it's a duel time Oh yet
again you gotta build tension come on
you're a cold-blooded murder
so what brings did it is the party tab
oh come on
sure hurdle for life where am I
I find myself oh god that was that
wasn't me how are you I saw you you cold
yeah each other yeah I totally sad yeah
would you stop me first you get more
points
it's another duos now when you're such a
murderer okay I'm uh I'm a Pierce Pierce
your nipple we send each other but you
were first
how are you first that's bull crap whoa
whoa
use your gadget you oh okay so now we
have a gun and some smoke so many people
so you have smoke and I have a gun
that's it Oh someone stabbed someone
over there I wonder what's up with that
that's weird
you're a stupid tactic oh my god there's
a storm brewing that's what you do it
like it wasn't hard enough to find
yourself oh my god I can't see anything
now
I found you okay okay there's salmon
I'm fast why because they're so bad drug
town sheriff
shoot friends you get one pretty nice
you get one hour per dead friend
nice I'm the sheriff oh I accidentally
kill you amazing gonna get drunk I'm
still the sheriff like how am I supposed
to figure out oh okay
it kills everyone in front of me it's
the best game ever isn't it Myrtle come
on Larry don't be a pal Myrtle let's try
one other game mode spider I like that
I'm gonna win okay sorry
whatever you think oh god there's snakes
everywhere
okay mine
I got a decoy you're gonna trap that's
pretty cool you should try your trap
everything what happened get it no I
Gillian I'm gonna kill you
you have to use your power up front what
happened over there hmm no can I get you
yes three hours after you plead to that
are you okay are you being challenged
you you're tricking me are you stabbing
a bunch of innocent people over there I
don't know I know where you are hope
you're proud I see you what
anyway learned owner dole thank you for
watching kids episode
don't don't watch it
brofist sword don't hurt him